No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks Copilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs to help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work.
没有人会为了汉克的电子表格而去汉克的店里，他们是为了吃上一块美味的披萨。不过最近，店里变得有点安静。因此，汉克决定重新推出1美元一幅的切块披萨。他让微软Excel中的Copilot查看他的销售额和成本，以帮助他评估自己是否能负担得起。Copilot向汉克展示了资金的去向，以及是哪些小配件让1美元披萨的方案得以实现。
Now, Hank has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365Copilot.com slash work. Illness is a part of life. But for people with health anxiety, worrying about sickness can become a constant struggle that can harm their mental health, their relationships, and even their physical health. Today we're going to talk to an expert in anxiety disorders about where health anxiety comes
现在，汉克的店门外排起了长队。汉克负责做披萨，Copilot负责处理电子表格。访问 M365Copilot.com/work 了解更多信息。生病是生活的一部分。但对于有健康焦虑症的人来说，担心生病可能会变成一场无休止的挣扎，从而损害他们的心理健康、人际关系，甚至是身体健康。今天，我们将与一位焦虑症专家探讨健康焦虑症的根源、
from, how to know whether your worries about illness are actually health anxiety, and what you can do if you or someone close to you is struggling with it. So how common is health anxiety? What's the difference between health anxiety and just being careful about your health? Did the pandemic cause an uptick in health anxiety or exacerbated in people who are prone to it? What about the internet and Dr. Google? And what are the most effective research-backed treatments we have for health anxiety? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Karen Lynn Cassidy,
如何判断你对疾病的担忧是否真的是健康焦虑症，以及如果你或你身边的人正在为此苦苦挣扎，你可以做些什么。那么，健康焦虑症有多常见？健康焦虑症与单纯注重健康有什么区别？大流行是否导致了健康焦虑症的激增，或者加剧了那些容易患上此病的人的病情？互联网和谷歌医生（Dr. Google）又扮演了什么角色？我们针对健康焦虑症有哪些最有效、有研究支持的治疗方法？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是凯伦·林·卡西迪博士（Dr. Karen Lynn Cassidy），
the owner and clinical director of the Anxiety Treatment Center of Greater Chicago. She's a former president of the Anxiety and Depression Association of America and a nationally recognized expert in diagnosing and treating anxiety disorders in children, teens, and adults. Her 2022 book, Freedom from Health Anxiety, understand and overcome obsessive worry about your health, or someone else's and find peace of mind, offers readers practical advice for overcoming health anxiety. Dr. Cassidy has spoken widely to the media on anxiety disorders, including through the New York Times, the Wall Street Journal, The Chicago Tribune, and The Today Show. Thank you for joining me, Dr. Cassidy.
她是芝加哥大都市区焦虑症治疗中心（Anxiety Treatment Center of Greater Chicago）的所有者和临床主任。她曾任美国焦虑与抑郁症协会（Anxiety and Depression Association of America）主席，是诊断和治疗儿童、青少年及成人焦虑症的全国知名专家。她2022年出版的书籍《摆脱健康焦虑：理解并克服对你或他人健康的强迫性担忧，重获内心的平静》（Freedom from Health Anxiety, Understand and Overcome Obsessive Worry About Your Health, or Someone Else's and Find Peace of Mind），为读者提供了克服健康焦虑的实用建议。卡西迪博士曾在各大媒体上广泛谈论焦虑症相关话题，包括《纽约时报》、《华尔街日报》、《芝加哥论坛报》和《今日秀》节目。非常感谢您能参加我们的节目，卡西迪博士。
Kim, thank you so much. I'm glad to be here. Let's start with a basic question. What exactly is health anxiety? Is it a separate and formal diagnosis in the DSM or any other diagnostic manual? Well, the good news is it actually has its own category called illness anxiety disorder. And that's in the DSM. And prior to that time, it was one of those orphans where clinicians would see it. We'd wonder, is it OCD? Is it just a warrior who's stuck on illness?
金，非常感谢你。很高兴来到这里。让我们从一个基本问题开始。究竟什么是健康焦虑症？它在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）或任何其他诊断手册中是一个独立且正式的诊断吗？嗯，好消息是，它确实有自己的分类，叫做疾病焦虑障碍（illness anxiety disorder）。这在《DSM》中是有记载的。在此之前，它属于那种“无依无靠”的疾病，临床医生会遇到它，我们当时会想：这强迫症（OCD）吗？这只是一个对疾病执迷不悟的焦虑者吗？
Is it somebody, you know, a hypochondriac? And research has shown this is actually a distinct disorder. And that's very helpful because it means now that medical providers can more accurately understand what happens when someone's worry is making them seek excessive treatment or reassurance or avoid them. It means that we have good research about how to work with it, as opposed to just thinking of it, oh, that's those chronic warriors or those people who just want attention from medical people. So are there specific characteristics that you have to have in
这难道是一个……你知道的，疑病症患者吗？研究表明，这其实是一种截然不同的障碍。这非常有帮助，因为这意味着医疗服务提供者现在可以更准确地理解当一个人的担忧导致他们寻求过度的治疗、寻求安慰或回避这些治疗时，究竟发生了什么。这意味着我们有了关于如何应对这种疾病的优质研究，而不仅仅是把它看作“那些慢性担忧者”或“那些只想引起医务人员注意的人”。那么，要想符合这一诊断，是否必须具备特定的特征？具体有哪些特征？
order to meet the diagnosis and what are those? Yes. And so here's the interesting thing. You have to actually have some kind of physical symptom. The dilemma is that many people think, including medical doctors, that this is something you make up or manufacture. But we see it always starts with someone noticing something and it could be their stomach doesn't feel right. their stool looks different, they're dizzy, they see a rash. And then what happens next is the person gets excessive, uncontrolled worry and they start believing it could be a sign of something serious. And serious usually means either something that could kill you or something that could
是的。有趣的是：你实际上必须有某种身体症状。困惑之处在于，许多人（包括医生）认为这是你凭空捏造或伪造出来的。但我们发现，这种情况总是始于某人注意到某些异常，比如他们的胃感觉不对劲、
disable you. And it has to last. So this isn't just something that haps for a week or two. It's got to go on for, you know, six months. And most people I work with, it started in childhood, that they can remember when they were a kid, when they were in health class, someone talked about heart attacks, and then they're worrying, they're having a heart attack, and they're only in fifth grade. Or they're in college, and they're thinking, you know, they have some, you know, multiple sclerosis,
大便看起来不一样、感到头晕、或者看到皮疹。接下来发生的是，这个人会产生过度且不受控制的担忧，并开始相信这可能是某种严重疾病的征兆。而“严重”通常意味着要么是可能致命的疾病，要么是可能导致你残疾的疾病。并且这种情况必须持续。所以这不仅仅是持续一周或两周的事情。它必须持续，你知道的，六个月之久。和我合作的大多数人，这种症状在童年时期就开始了。他们还记得自己还是个孩子、在上健康课时，有人谈到了心脏病发作，然后他们就开始担心自己会心脏病发作，而他们当时才上五年级。或者他们在上大学时，会认为自己患有某种……你知道的，多发性硬化症，
you know, because they were hung over and they were dizzy, and they, you know, weren't sure if that was a serious change. So that's what we see is the uncontrolled worry. It's focused on illness. It's been going on and they can't get rid of it. And then the other thing we see is the person then reacts to that worry with either reassurance seeking. And this is where Dr. Google comes in or having, you know, a long-term relationship with WebMD or constantly talking to others to see, oh my gosh, you know, have you ever had this?
因为他们宿醉头晕，不确定这是否是一种严重的身体变化。这就是我们看到的不受控制的担忧。它专注于疾病，并且持续存在且无法摆脱。然后我们看到的另一类现象是，患者随后会对这种担忧做出反应，表现为要么寻求安慰。这就是谷歌医生（Dr. Google）登场的时候，或者与WebMD（网页医学）建立“长期关系”，或者不断与他人交谈，看“天哪，你以前有过这种情况吗？
you okay? Was it something serious? Reading obituaries to see have other people my age died from that? You know, is it more likely I have that? Or avoidance. And we have people where they're afraid to see the doctor because they're convinced they're going to get the horrible news this time. And sadly, they forego necessary and helpful health care. Now, it used to be called just hypochondria or hypocondriasis. Why was the name changed? Well, for very good reason, that name had a lot of connections to, I'm going to say, old school Freudian psychology. And the implication was there was a subconscious reason that you wanted to be sick, that it was somehow a, you know, diversion of your need for attachment or
你没事吧？这是什么大病吗？”阅读讣告，看看是否有其他像我这个年龄的人死于这种病？你知道，我患这种病的可能性更大吗？或者表现为回避。有些患者害怕去看医生，因为他们确信这次一定会听到可怕的消息。遗憾的是，他们因此放弃了必要且有益的医疗保健。以前，这仅仅被称为疑病症（hypochondria）或疑病倾向（hypochondriasis）。为什么要改名呢？嗯，原因非常充分，这个名字与——我要说的是——老派弗洛伊德心理学有很多联系。其暗示的含义是，你潜意识里希望自己生病，这在某种程度上是将你对依恋的需求或
your need for relationships onto medical personnel or medical situations. And so when they were coming up with a name, they really wanted to make people understand this is an anxiety disorder. And one of the unique things about all anxiety disorders is in order to have them, you could be anyone. You could have any kind of wonderful coping or very poor coping. And in fact, what you really need to get an anxiety disorder is a genetic pre-loaning. And then a background where people are showing you it's bad to be scared and you better seek reinsurance or check or get help or avoid. And then you have those things mixed together, then we end up with anxiety disorders and also illness anxiety disorder.
对人际关系的需求，转移到了医务人员或医疗情况上。因此，在他们构思新名称时，他们非常希望人们明白这是一种焦虑症。所有焦虑症的一个独特之处在于，要患上焦虑症，任何人都有可能。你可能拥有任何优秀的应对机制，也可能拥有非常糟糕的应对机制。事实上，真正让你患上焦虑症的前提是具备遗传倾向。再加上一个周围人向你展示“害怕是一件坏事，你最好去寻求安慰、检查、寻求帮助或回避”的成长背景。当这些因素交织在一起时，我们最终就会患上焦虑症以及疾病焦虑障碍。
And what's so interesting is I've yet to meet a patient who has illness anxiety disorder who doesn't know someone in their family who was always going to die. And one patient told me, oh, my God, I didn't know there's a thing. You know, my mom, she was always, you know, going to die. She knew it. She would be saying novenas. She would be doing all these special things. And then she'd get past it.
非常有趣的是，我至今还没有遇到过哪个患有疾病焦虑障碍的患者，其家族里没有一个整天觉得“自己快要死了”的人。有个患者告诉我：“天哪，我不知道这居然是一种病。你知道的，我妈妈总是觉得她快要死了。她对此深信不疑。她会去做九日敬礼（novenas）。她会做所有这些特殊的事情。然后她挺过来了。
And then it would be another thing. And so we see, that's probably that learning component where you see someone showing you how you should handle information about illness anxiety. There's one other important point about illness anxiety where we see this group of people with anxiety disorders is different from other anxiety disorders. And that is they view illness and death and dying as being unusually tragic. And so instead of seeing the process of aging or getting sick or having things happen to people's health as I'm going to say a normal part of life or a challenging part of life, they view it as especially terrible and awful and tragic. And then we think that also sort of predisposes them
接着又是另一回事。”所以我们看到，这可能就是那种学习机制：你看到有人向你展示了如何处理关于疾病焦虑的信息。关于疾病焦虑，还有另一个重要观点，展示了这群患有焦虑症的人与其他焦虑症患者的不同之处。那就是：他们将疾病、死亡和临终视为异常的悲剧。因此，他们没有将衰老、生病或健康问题视作——我要说的是——生活的正常部分或充满挑战的部分，而是将其视为特别可怕、糟糕和悲剧的事情。我们认为，这也某种程度上使他们
to overreact to the idea of having a serious illness. Now, you mentioned that there might have been a family member who was always worried about being sick and dying. Does that indicate that there is some kind of a genetic component or is it just something that you learned by example? Actually, if we were to look at people with anxiety disorders, 70 to 80 percent of them, including illness anxiety disorder, have a first-degree relative who might have an anxiety disorder or a mood disorder. And then we also see about 70 to 80 percent of them have a second or a third or a fourth anxiety disorder.
倾向于对患有严重疾病的想法产生过度反应。现在，你提到可能有一个家庭成员总是担心生病和死亡。这是否表明存在某种遗传成分，或者这只是通过榜样学习学到的？事实上，如果我们观察焦虑症患者，其中70%到80%的人（包括疾病焦虑障碍患者）都有一位患有焦虑症或情绪障碍的一级亲属。我们还发现，大约70%到80%的人患有第二、第三或第四种焦虑症。
So we see they're inherited in clusters. And so the typical course is most of my patients I see for illness anxiety disorder, have it other times met criteria for panic disorder or OCD or a specific phobia or social anxiety disorder. And so what you inherit is the tendency to get anxiety disorders in general. And then we believe that life circumstances or accidental role modeling, you know, someone who also has that anxiety makes it happen. And one thing I forgot to mention is you can have illness anxiety disorder about someone you love. Okay. So some of you can remember your mother constantly checking you for fever
所以我们看到它们是成簇遗传的。典型的病程是，我因疾病焦虑障碍而接诊的大多数患者，在其他时期也曾符合恐慌症、强迫症（OCD）、特定恐惧症或社交焦虑症的诊断标准。因此，你遗传的是总体上容易患焦虑症的倾向。然后我们认为，生活环境或偶然的角色建模（比如某个同样患有这种焦虑的人）促成了它的发生。还有一件事我忘了提，你可能会对你所爱的人产生疾病焦虑障碍。好吧。所以你们中的一些人可能还记得你的母亲不断检查你是否发烧，
and not letting you play if you had any sign of anything and taking you to the pediatrician way more than you realized other children were going. I'm going to put my money on a possible diagnosis of health anxiety there. Well, how common is actual illness anxiety disorder? That's an interesting question. If we look at the most recent studies, we're looking at anywhere from 3 to 4.5% or 5%. However, because this diagnosis is relatively new and isn't often included in these large population surveys, we're not exactly sure. And one of the things that many clinicians who work with anxiety disorder see is, it's kind of like now that we have a diagnosis, all of a sudden, the rates are going up. And we think that's because many of these people
如果你有任何不适的迹象就不让你玩，并且带你去儿科医生的频率远超你所意识到的其他孩子。我敢打包票，那里可能存在健康焦虑症的诊断。那么，真正的疾病焦虑障碍到底有多常见？这是一个有趣的问题。如果我们看一下最近的研究，这一比例大约在3%到4.5%或5%之间。然而，由于这种诊断相对较新，且通常不包括在这些大型人口普查中，我们并不完全确定。处理焦虑症的许多临床医生发现的一点是：这就好像现在我们有了诊断名称，患病率突然上升了。我们认为这是因为许多这类患者
were included in other categories like OCD or panic disorder or generalized anxiety disorder. So some people are estimating it could be double that amount. We just don't know for sure. And I'm hoping, you know, probably in the next 10 years or so, we'll have a much better picture. And then the other dilemma is you mentioned the pandemic. And one of the things that is certainly true is when there are large-scale news stories about, I'm going to say, frightening health things, such as Ebola or when the coronavirus first came out, we see that the rates go up. And we think that's people who are vulnerable. they hadn't yet been triggered. And then they're getting constant uncertainty. And we see that uncertainty is the thing that people with illness, anxiety, have trouble with because they detect a real symptom.
以前被归入其他类别，如强迫症、恐慌症或广泛性焦虑障碍。因此，有些人估计实际数字可能是这个数字的两倍。我们只是无法确切得知。我希望，你知道的，大概在未来10年左右，我们会有一个更清晰的图景。另一个困境是你刚才提到的大流行。毫无疑问，当出现大规模的关于——我要说的是——可怕健康事件的新闻报道时，比如埃博拉病毒或冠状病毒刚爆发时，我们发现发病率确实会上升。我们认为这是那些脆弱人群的表现。他们以前尚未被触发。接着他们面临着持续的不确定性。我们发现，不确定性正是患有疾病焦虑症的人难以应付的事情，因为他们察觉到了一个真实的症状。
But it's almost never actually a serious symptom. And it's the kind of symptom that other people would probably sit on and say, I'll wait a few weeks before I get worried about this rash. Or, okay, you know, I was partying hard the last couple of nights. maybe I won't worry about this dizziness that I have. It's possibly a hangover. So they pull the trigger fast getting that. And so we did see during the pandemic way, way more calls and people worried about it.
但这几乎从来都不是一个真正的严重症状。这种症状是其他人可能会搁置不管并认为“我再等几周再去担心这个皮疹”的症状。或者，“好吧，你知道的，我前几个晚上玩得很疯狂。也许我不必担心我这种头晕。这可能只是宿醉。”所以他们很快就会触发这种反应。因此，在大流行期间，我们确实看到了更多、更多的求助电话和对此感到焦虑的人。
The other thing we saw during the pandemic is that anxiety disorders in general are going up, especially for people age 35 and younger. and we see that this population appears to be uniquely vulnerable. We think some of it may be because of the culture of parenting we've had the last 30 years that has de-emphasized risk-taking, tolerance of uncertainty, and de-emphasized trusting your own judgment. And so when you don't trust your own judgment, then you always think, I've got to have an expert like a doctor or a nurse help out.
我们在大流行期间看到的另一件事是，整体焦虑症发病率正在上升，特别是对于35岁及以下的人群。我们发现这一人群似乎具有独特的脆弱性。我们认为部分原因可能与过去30年的育儿文化有关，这种文化淡化了冒险精神、对不确定性的容忍度，并淡化了对自身判断力的信任。因此，当你不再信任自己的判断力时，你就会总是认为：我必须找个专家（比如医生或护士）来帮忙。
You know, another dilemma that goes with the pandemic and with media is, you know, once you look something up, then the AI system in your computer and on the internet is going to feed you that like a fire hose. And then the more that happens, the more you get. And then that gives people the misperception, you know, oh my God, this is terrible. So you might have recently seen there was a big article about microplastics and how they're everywhere. And I can't remember was it at the Atlantic, the New York Times or the Wall Street. It's one of those prestigious publications that people
你知道，与大流行和媒体相关的另一个困境是，一旦你搜索了某些内容，你电脑和互联网上的AI系统就会像消防水管一样向你倾倒相关信息。这种现象越频繁，你收到的信息就越多。这给人们带来了一种错误的认知，即“天哪，这太可怕了”。因此，你可能最近看到了一篇关于微塑料及其无处不在的大文章。我记不清是在《大西洋月刊》、《纽约时报》还是《华尔街日报》上看到的了。这是那些人们认为
go, they're credible. Well, then of course what happened to many of my patients, they saw that. So all of a sudden they had all these people terrified that they were going to get all kinds of cancers and heart disease due to microplastic pollution and trying to figure out how could you eliminate it from your life and just going nuts over it. And it was an artifact of the way we receive information. And then also, you've got to remember, if you are a news outlet and you want someone to pay attention, something that scares people or is gruesome gets their attention better and it's more likely gets them to click on it or to look longer than something neutral. And I kind of think of it this way.
非常权威的声誉卓著的出版物之一。嗯，接下来发生在我许多患者身上的事情当然是：他们看到了那篇报道。因此，他们突然都变得惊恐万分，害怕由于微塑料污染而患上各种癌症和心脏病，并试图找出如何将其从生活中彻底根除的方法，为此急得发疯。这是我们接收信息方式的一种产物。此外，你必须记住，如果你是一家新闻机构，并且你想吸引人们的注意力，那些让人感到害怕或毛骨悚然的事情更能吸引他们的注意力，而且比中性内容更容易让他们点击或停留更长时间。我是这样想的：
You know, when the pandemic started, you had the National Public Radio headline. Unusual virus outbreak in city in China, scientists investigating. And then you had, you know, the ABC one, which was dangerous virus, you know, getting loose in China might infect millions. And then you had the Fox News headline of millions could die because of terrible virus. And I literally saw these headlines all in one day. And this is before we even realized there was going to be a pandemic. And, you know, if you are someone that has the tendency for an anxiety disorder, then your brain can do something special that's kind of inconvenient. it can do single trial learning or it can have one exposure to something that's scary,
你知道，当大流行开始时，你看到了美国国家公共广播电台（NPR）的头条新闻：“中国某城市发生罕见病毒爆发，科学家正在调查。”然后你看到了美国广播公司（ABC）的头条：“中国失控的危险病毒可能感染数百万人。”接着你看到了福克斯新闻（Fox News）的头条：“可怕病毒可能导致数百万人死亡。”我简直在同一天看到了所有这些头条新闻。而这甚至发生在我们意识到会有大流行之前。而且，如果你是一个有焦虑症倾向的人，那么你的大脑就会做出一种特别的、有点不太方便的事情：
one trigger, and then it gets set in, where people that didn't inherit that might take quite a few more exposure to something before they start getting scared and worried and their body reacts. And, you know, so when those things all work together, it's really tough if you are one of those people that gets worried about serious illness. It's kind of like you have to learn to cultivate what your news environment is going to be, what your social media is going to be, as well as doing the things that would help you get better. Have you ever rearranged your furniture and discovered the carpet underneath looks brand new while the rest of it looks, well, not so new? It's time for a carpet upgrade. At the Home Depot, we have stylish choices at simple prices from
它能进行单次试验学习（single trial learning），或者只需接触一次可怕的事物、触发一次，就会根深蒂固；而那些没有遗传这种倾向的人可能需要接触更多次才会开始感到害怕、担忧以及身体产生反应。所以，当这些因素共同作用时，如果你恰好是那些对严重疾病感到担忧的人，情况就会变得非常艰难。这就好比你必须学会培养你的新闻环境、你的社交媒体环境，同时还要做那些能帮助你康复的事情。你有没有重新摆放过家具，却发现底下的地毯看起来崭新无比，而其余部分看起来……嗯，没那么新了？是时候升级地毯了。在The Home Depot（全国家居建材店），我们以实惠的价格提供来自
all the top brands. Best of all, we can install it for you, starting at only 49 cents per square foot. So all you have to do is pick your perfect floor. Start your carpet project today at the Home Depot. How doers get more done. Exclusions apply for licenses, see Home Depot.com slash license numbers. Now, we talked a moment ago about Dr. Google, and I'm just wondering about the advent of the internet and how that may have affected the prevalence of health anxiety.
各大顶级品牌的时尚选择。最棒的是，我们可以为您安装，每平方英尺仅需49美分起。所以你只需挑选你完美的地板。今天就在The Home Depot开启你的地毯项目吧。实干者成就更多。许可限制适用，请参见 HomeDepot.com/license-numbers。现在，我们刚才谈到了谷歌医生，我想知道互联网的出现及其对健康焦虑症患病率的影响。
I mean, back in the old days, if you wanted to know about illness, you had to go to the library and go get a Merck manual and look things up. But now, yeah, you remember that, right? But now... Yeah, you had to find a medical library even. You couldn't even go to the public library. You had to find the nearest medical school. And now it's everywhere, but a lot of the information is not great.
我的意思是，在过去的日子里，如果你想了解疾病，你必须去图书馆拿一本默克诊疗手册（Merck Manual）来查阅。但现在，是的，你还记得那个，对吧？但现在……是的，你甚至得找个医学图书馆。你甚至不能去公共图书馆。你必须找到最近的医学院。现在它无处不在，但很多信息并不好。
So what's happening as a result of everybody being out there able to diagnose themselves for a person who doesn't have illness, anxiety? It's pretty terrible. but somebody who actually has it, it just must be magnified a thousand times. It is. I think of the internet like crack cocaine for people that have illness anxiety disorder. It is, it's so hard to manage that. And I can't tell you how many patients I have where they have all these quick tabs for various
所以，当每个人都能为自己诊断时，结果会怎样呢？对于一个没有疾病焦虑症的人来说，这还算可以忍受。但对于一个真正患有此病的人来说，这一定被放大了上千倍。确实如此。我认为互联网就像是患有疾病焦虑 disorder 的人的快克可卡因（crack cocaine）。它是如此难以控制。我数不清我有多少患者，他们为各种
medical sites. They're on Reddit. They're on various social media. They're photographing pictures of symptoms or them and the way they walk to see if anybody thinks it looks weird. And I believe, and many of the experts in the field believe this has, I'm going to say, help lower the threshold for people who are at risk for getting it. And it's definitely increased the problem for people and made it, I'm going to say it's, well, it's the same problem we have with fentanyl in the substance use world, is that we have drugs out there where you can get addicted fast and they're terrible. The internet is like that for people that worry about their health. And then the other thing, I think that's so difficult, and I have to say all of you who are listening,
医疗网站保留了所有这些快速标签页。他们在Reddit上。他们在各种社交媒体上。他们拍摄自己症状的照片，或者拍摄自己走路的姿态，想看看是否有人觉得看起来很奇怪。我相信，并且该领域的许多专家也相信，这——我要说的是——降低了那些有患病风险的人的门槛。它绝对加剧了人们的问题，并使它变得——我要说的是——嗯，这与我们在物质使用领域面临的芬太尼问题一样，那就是市面上有些药物能让你迅速上瘾，而且它们非常可怕。互联网对那些担心自己健康的人来说就是这样。还有一件事，我认为非常艰难，我必须对所有正在收听的你们说：
I am so proud of you for being smart and coming to a site that vets its information and has very high quality standards for how information gets conveyed to the public, there are a million and one people who claim to be an expert or who claim to have published something. And if you follow it through, you find that's not true or it was a self-published thing as opposed to peer reviewed, which means experts decided it was worthy. And that is, I'd have to say with every single patient I have, unless it's someone who for some reason is not using the internet, that is their greatest struggle. It's the internet. It's easier to manage all the other things.
我为你们聪明并访问一个对信息进行审核、对向公众传达的信息有着极高质量标准的网站感到无比自豪。有一百多万自称专家或声称发表过文章的人。如果你深究下去，你会发现这并不是真的，或者它只是自费出版的东西，而不是经过同行评审的（即由专家认定其有价值的）。我不得不说，对于我的每一个患者（除非由于某种原因不使用互联网的人），这都是他们最大的挣扎。这就是互联网。其他所有事情都比较容易处理。
The internet is the big, big addiction. But what about doctor shopping? I mean, is there some responsibility on the part of the medical establishment where they keep seeing these people who over and over and over again, you know, I need to have another mammogram? I just had one last month, but I felt a lump yesterday. Well, you're bringing up a very interesting problem. This is where I'm going to say capitalism and the anxiety threshold of the medical provider and the patient can all interact in a bad way.
互联网才是那个巨大无比的“瘾”。但是，频繁换医生（doctor shopping）呢？我的意思是，医疗机构是否存在某种责任，因为他们不断地看到这些人一遍又一遍地——“我需要做另一个乳房X光检查吗？我上个月刚做过，但我昨天摸到一个肿块。”嗯，你提出了一个非常有趣的问题。这就是我所说的资本主义、医疗提供者的焦虑阈值以及患者的焦虑阈值三者产生不良互动的领域。
So some clinics and establishments are happy to keep doing more and more procedures because they make money. that the most profit-worthy things in a hospital system or a clinic are going to be procedures and labs. And so we see pressure on doctors. I have friends who are physicians and nurses, and depending on the system there, and there's pressure to use those procedures codes and to order them. It helps them stay profitable or to get paid. Then we have another problem, which is what happens if you run into a provider who's always worried about making a mistake. And providers can have illness anxiety disorder. And they can have generalized anxiety disorder where they're worriers.
因此，一些诊所和机构很乐意继续做越来越多的手术，因为他们能赚钱。医院系统或诊所中最具利润的往往是手术和实验室检查。因此，我们看到医生面临着压力。我有一些身为医生和护士的朋友，根据他们所在的系统以及相关体系，他们面临着使用这些程序代码并开具处方的压力。这有助于他们保持盈利或获得报酬。然后我们遇到了另一个问题：如果你遇到一个总是担心犯错的医疗提供者，会发生什么？医疗提供者也会患上疾病焦虑障碍。
And I've talked to many people who are saying, well, I got worried, you know, what if this time? Because the patient is saying, well, maybe I've been okay. I've made it this far. But this time it feels different. Doctor, my stomach is different. I really think it's colon cancer. And then if that physician can't or nurse can't,
他们也可能患有广泛性焦虑障碍，从而成为焦虑者。我和许多人交谈过，他们说：“我当时很担心，万一这次……”因为患者在说：“也许我一直都挺好的。我坚持到了这一步。但这次感觉不一样。医生，我的胃不一样了。我真的觉得这是结肠癌。”然后，如果这位医生或护士无法
stay grounded in their standards for what they use for anyone, then they start getting swayed to give in. And then we have the people who believe their kind. And you have to remember, the average medical provider has had three months, if at all, of training in a psychiatric unit unless they're a psychiatrist. And so they don't know how to diagnose an anxiety disorder. They haven't been given any training. It's not considered part of their purview. And many providers think, well, you know, okay, if we just do this MRI, then they won't worry about brain cancer. If we just do this mammogram, you know, we'll just make them feel better. If we just do this lab or do another one, then that, they do that. And when you have those three different phenomena
坚守他们对所有患者一视同仁的标准，那么他们就会开始动摇并妥协。然后我们还有那些相信自己是出于好心的人。你必须记住，普通医疗提供者在精神科病房的培训时间只有三个月（甚至根本没有），除非他们本身是精神科医生。因此，他们不知道如何诊断焦虑症。他们没有接受过任何培训。这不被认为是他们职责范围内的事情。许多医疗提供者认为：“好吧，你知道的，如果我们只做这个MRI（磁共振成像），他们就不会担心脑癌了。如果我们只做这个乳房X光检查，你知道的，我们就能让他们感觉好点。如果我们只做这项实验室检查或再做一项，那就……”他们就这样做了。当你遇到这三种不同现象
not happening, it makes the person who's suffering worse because it plays into their anxiety and they can never discover, I can tolerate the uncertainty. I can trust my own judgment that nothing bad is happening and I don't need to get reassurance or be scared or think that the odds have changed for me. You know, another dilemma that I see for patients is the medical record where you can go on and you can see your lab results before the doctor ever gets to review them or the radiologist. And this is a new pain point for many, many people where I have patients where part of our treatment is you can never look at that until a trained person observes it and interprets it to you. Why?
并未消退时，这会使受苦的人病情加重，因为它加剧了他们的焦虑，使他们永远无法发现：“我可以忍受不确定性。我可以相信自己的判断，知道没有什么坏事发生，我不需要寻求安慰、感到害怕，也不需要认为我的概率发生了变化。”你知道，我为患者看到的另一个困境是医疗记录系统，你可以登录并在医生或放射科医生审核之前查看你的实验室结果。对于许多许多人来说，这是一个新的痛点。我的部分治疗方案是：在经过培训的人员观察并向你解释之前，你绝对不能查看这些内容。为什么？
Because there's a wide range of normal. And just because your result is not perfectly in the green zone because my, you know, my chart, whatever, it has green, yellow, red. And for all my patients, they feel like, you know, it's trying to get an A plus on a test. I want everything to be in the green zone. And they don't understand. Most people aren't always in the green. There's some yellows in there, and that's normal.
因为正常值有一个广泛的范围。仅仅因为你的结果没有完美地落在绿色区域——因为我的——你知道的，“我的图表”（MyChart）或其他什么系统有绿色、黄色、红色。对我的所有患者来说，他们觉得（你知道的）就像是在考试中争取拿A+。我希望一切都在绿色区域。但他们并不明白。大多数人并不总是处于绿色状态。里面会有一些黄色，那是正常的。
And so that's another area where this attempt to be, you know, have all this technology is backfiring for this particular group of people. So you just mentioned one technique to help people. people who have this anxiety. How do you treat it? How do you get people to come off the ledge and stop worrying about their health day in and day out? The great news is we've got a lot of research and it shows us several things that are very helpful. So the first one is if you've never had any treatment before, the best thing you can do is to find someone who does cognitive behavioral therapy that focuses on exposure to the things you're scared of and the situations you're scared of. And what that means is learning to have a symptom without immediately going to Dr. Google or
所以这是另一个领域，这种试图拥有所有这些技术的做法正在对这特定一群人产生反作用。你刚才提到了帮助患有这种焦虑的人的一种技术。你如何治疗它？你如何让人们从悬崖边退回来，不再日复一日地担心他们的健康？好消息是，我们有很多研究，它们向我们展示了几个非常有帮助的方法。所以第一点是，如果你从未接受过任何治疗，你能做的最好的事情就是找一个从事认知行为疗法（CBT）的人，这种疗法侧重于让你暴露于你害怕的事物和害怕的情境中。这意味着学会忍受一种症状，而不是立即去求助于谷歌医生或
WebMD, without talking to someone to find out if it's normal or if others have it, without reading stories or doing research, and to learn that your anxiety is going to go down. Another component it is to do a special kind of worry exposure practice where you imagine yourself to have the terrible thing that you're scared of. And the reason this works is that for people who worry about that, they think of it in sort of scary little spurt, but they never process it fully and they never get used to it. And it's kind of like if you ever saw an old scary movie, you know, when you were a kid and then ran out of the room and then never saw it again. You got more and more scared. But then probably when you're older, you went back and you watched it and you're like, what was I so scared of? Oh my gosh,
WebMD，不与他人交谈以查明它是否正常或别人是否有过，不阅读故事或做研究，并学会你的焦虑会自行消退。另一个组成部分是进行一种特殊的担忧暴露练习，即想象自己患上了你害怕的那种可怕疾病。这种方法之所以奏效，是因为对于那些为此担忧的人来说，他们是以一种可怕的小爆发的方式去思考它的，但他们从未完全加工它，也从未习惯它。这就好比如果你小时候看过一部可怕的老恐怖电影，
that wasn't that bad. Well, we do the same thing where you create a movie in your mind about your scary story and you listen to it over and over. And what happens is your body gets used to it. Your mind starts to realize this is just a scary idea. It's not reality. It's not happening me now, and you can respond appropriately. And then the cognitive therapy, where we can use inference-based cognitive therapy, regular cognitive therapy, acceptance and commitment therapy, all focuses on the same thing, which is learning. I don't have to believe the scary signal I get every time I think about serious illness or
然后跑出房间，再也没有看过它。你会越来越害怕。但当你长大后，你可能会回去看它，然后想：“我当时到底在害怕什么？天哪，这没那么糟糕。”嗯，我们在做同样的事情：你在脑海中围绕你的恐怖故事创作一部电影，然后一遍又一遍地听它。发生的情况是，你的身体习惯了它。你的大脑开始意识到这只是一个可怕的想法。这不是现实。它现在并没有发生在我身上，你可以做出适当的反应。然后是认知疗法，我们可以使用基于推理的认知疗法、常规认知疗法、接纳承诺疗法（ACT），所有这些都集中在同一件事上，那就是学习：我不需要相信每次我想到严重疾病或
I accidentally imagine I might have the beginning symptoms of it. And I can teach my body to relax, to tone down, and I can get through the moment, and then it keeps getting easier and easier and easier. And that's the beauty of that exposure-based therapy. And then the other thing that we see is helpful is if you have the misfortune of being, from having a lot of relatives and ancestors who had anxiety, or you have other anxiety disorders that are very difficult, then medication might be very helpful. And when medication works, what it does is people say, I feel normal. The thoughts don't get stuck the way they used to. My body doesn't get over-accelerated
偶然想象自己可能有它的初期症状时所收到的可怕信号。我可以教我的身体放松、减弱反应，我能够度过这一刻，然后情况会变得越来越容易、越来越容易、越来越容易。这就是基于暴露的疗法的魅力所在。此外，我们发现有帮助的另一件事是，如果你不幸拥有许多患有焦虑症的亲戚和祖先，或者你患有非常严重的其他焦虑症，那么药物治疗可能会非常有帮助。当药物起作用时，人们会说：“我觉得自己很正常。那些想法不会像以前那样卡在脑子里了。我的身体不会像以前那样
the way I used to. And we see that it just sort of slows down the process in your body and your mind so that you have a fighting chance to think healthy thoughts and to respond appropriately. And so I want to let people know, you know, my standard is if after two months we aren't seeing some visible progress, then we think about possibly adding medication, you know, because we don't want someone to suffer because we see these cognitive behavioral therapies are very effective and can work quite rapidly when we get you to do it. And then the other thing you got to do is there's a response prevention component. And that's where you realize I have to give up all these things that I do for a quick fix of
过度加速了。”我们看到它只是减缓了你身体和大脑中的过程，让你有机会进行健康的思考并做出适当的反应。因此，我想让大家知道，我的标准是，如果两个月后我们没有看到任何可见的进展，那么我们会考虑可能增加药物治疗，你知道的，因为我们不想让任何人受苦，因为我们发现这些认知行为疗法非常有效，当我们让你去做时，它们可以相当迅速地起作用。然后你需要做的另一件事是包含反应预防（response prevention）成分。这就是你意识到：我必须放弃所有为了获得
reassurance. So I can't research anymore. And so we try to cut that back or cut it out altogether. I may have to tell my doctor or my nurse practitioner, I have illness anxiety. And when I start to repeat the same questions, could you please just remind me I'm getting anxious and say you can't talk about it anymore. I even have a script in my book that you can hand to your doctors so they know a kind way to talk to you because most physicians and nurses want to be nice. They don't want to hurt you. They just don't know how to talk to someone who's anxious. And they don't realize saying don't worry isn't effective. And then it means also that you need to give up checking your body. So you might want to use one of those, a washcloth when you're washing yourself so you're not
快速安慰而做的事情。所以我不能再做研究了。因此，我们试图减少甚至完全切断这种行为。我可能不得不告诉我的医生或执业护士：“我有疾病焦虑障碍。当我开始重复相同的问题时，请提醒我我正在变得焦虑，并告诉我不能再谈论这个了。”我的书中甚至有一个脚本，你可以递给你的医生，让他们知道如何用一种友善的方式与你沟通，因为大多数医生和护士都想表现得友善。他们不想伤害你。他们只是不知道该如何与焦虑的人沟通。他们没有意识到说“别担心”是无效的。这也意味着你需要放弃检查自己的身体。所以当你洗澡时，你可能想用一块毛巾，这样你就不会
feeling for lumps or bumps or rashes. You might want to, you know, put a poster over the bottom of your mirror. If there's a part of your body, you keep checking to see if something changed and there's cancer growing. And then you might need to tell your partner or your anxious support system, we can't talk about illness anymore. And what I'd love for you to tell me when you see that I'm worrying. And usually your support system knows exactly when you're doing it to just say, it looks like
去摸索肿块、疙瘩或皮疹。你可能想要，你知道的，在镜子底部贴上一张海报。如果你的身体某个部位让你不断检查以防有什么变化和癌症在生长的话。然后你可能需要告诉你的伴侣或你的焦虑支持系统：“我们不能再谈论疾病了。”我希望当你看到我开始担忧时能提醒我。通常你的支持系统确切地知道你什么时候在这样做，只需说：“看起来你很焦虑。”还有哪些其他事情可以做是很有帮助的？这将是支持某人的最佳方式。
you're anxious. What are other things you can do that are helpful? And that would be the very best way to support someone. And then the other thing you may have to do, if you're one of those people that worries about other people, you're going to have to accept that you need to retire from practicing medicine without a license. And you need to realize that there's a reason they tell physicians and nurses don't treat your own family.
然后，如果你是那些担心别人的人，你可能还不得不做的一件事是：你必须接受你需要“无证行医退休”。你需要意识到，医生和护士被告知“不要治疗自己的家人”是有原因的。这是因为你无法真正保持客观，因为你在乎得太多，情绪会模糊你的判断。因此，你可能需要审视这一点并说：“我不是一个适合不断检查他们的人。我需要让我的伴侣或其他家长来检查这个孩子。我需要让我父母照顾他们自己的健康（谢谢），或者我的兄弟姐妹、我的伴侣”，并意识到无论他们的医疗提供者是谁，他们都对他们的健康有着既得利益。他们并不马虎。
It's because you can't really be objective because you care too much and emotion can cloud your judgment. And so you may need to look at this and say, I'm not a good person to keep checking them. I need to let my partner or the other parent check this child. I need to let my parents take care of their own health thank you or my siblings, my partner, and realize that whoever their health care provider is, they have a vested interest in their good health. They aren't sloppy.
他们只是没有过分担忧。任何一个优秀的担忧者都有一个错误信念：当我担忧时，我是在尽到责任。我是在关心。我是在向自己的健康、向其他人的健康表达爱意。当我审视他们、当我问这些问题、当我做所有这些深入研究时。我对任何人的建议是：你唯一被允许做任何医学研究的时候，是你真正被诊断出那个问题的时候。
They just aren't worrying. And one of the mistaken beliefs that any good warrior has is that when I worry, I'm being responsible. I'm being caring. I'm showing love to my health, to other people's health. when I look at them, when I ask these questions, when I do all this deep research. And my advice to anyone is the only time you're permitted to do any medical research is when you've actually been diagnosed with that problem.
否则，你根本没有资格这样做。此外，我还想对大家说，如果你们拥有医学知识——我意识到这个听众群体的医学和心理健康知识基础可能比正常人要大——你需要接受：你仍然不是那个为自己或他人诊断的人。把这留给专家，并意识到陷入那种假设只会加剧担忧。一个患有健康焦虑症的人将这种焦虑转移给他们的孩子的频率有多高？我的意思是，你提到了，你知道的，那位可能经常检查孩子、带孩子去
Otherwise, you have no business doing that. And also, I'd like to mention to people that this is a case where if you have medical knowledge and I realize this audience probably has a larger than normal base of knowledge about medical and mental health things, you need to accept you're still not the one to diagnose yourself or someone else. Leave it to the experts and realize getting into that assumption thing is just going to promote worry. How common is it for somebody who has a health anxiety disorder to actually transfer it to say, their children. I mean, you mentioned, you know, the mom who might be checking, taking the kid to the
儿科医生的妈妈。这种情况经常发生吗？这是这种障碍一个非常普遍的方面吗？是的。我不知道有哪些统计数据可以告诉你，但在我30多年的患者治疗生涯中，我想说80%的情况下，都有一个父母或祖父母（无论是男性还是女性）在充当榜样并进行大量的检查。这只是他们成长的方式。非常有趣的是，我们有许多患者，他们的想法——你知道的，当我告诉我们“我们要停止这样做”时，他们的第一反应是：“这太危险了。我怎么能停止观察这个、阅读这个、不咨询或不监测它呢？”他们之所以这么说，是因为他们从未见过
pediatrician too often. Does that happen a lot? And that's a very common aspect of this disorder? It is. I'm not aware of statistics I can tell you, but I can say in my 30 plus years of working with patients, I'm going to say 80% of the time there is a parent or a grandparent. And it could be either one, into male or female, who is role modeling that and doing a lot of checking. And this is just the way they grew up. And it's very interesting. We have a lot of patience that their idea, you know, when I say we're going to stop doing this, their first reaction is, that's dangerous. How could I stop looking at this or reading about it or not consulting about it or not monitoring it? And the reason they're saying that is because they've never sent
别人不这样做。他们认为世界上其余的人对待自己的健康非常马虎。而他们没有意识到的是：一定程度的良性忽视（benign neglect）对内心的平静大有裨益，也有助于腾出时间去做其他更有成效的事情。但是，我们所讨论的这些与诈病（factitious disorder）之间的界限又在哪里呢？我们在“心理学对话”中讨论过诈病，那是指父母不仅经常带孩子去看医生，而且实际上在做一些让孩子生病的事情。是的。是的，这与诈病完全不同。事实上，金，我很高兴你提到这一点，因为有时人们在看到焦虑的父母时，会认为这必然是诈病。我可以……
seen people not do that. And they're considering the rest of the world to be very sloppy with their health care. And as opposed to realizing that a certain amount of benign neglect is good for peace of mind and good to give you time to do other more productive things. But what about the line between this, what we're talking about, and factitious disorder, which we have talked about on speaking of psychology, where that's where the parent is, not only taking the child to the doctor a lot, but is actually doing things to make the child ill. Yes. Yes, this is very different from factitious disorder. And in fact, Kim, I'm so glad you mentioned that because sometimes people assume this must be that when they have an anxious parent. And I can give
见过有人不这样做。他们认为世界上其他人对待健康非常马虎。相反，他们没有意识到一定程度的良性忽视有利于保持内心的平静，并能腾出时间去做其他更有生产力的事。但是，我们刚才谈到的这种情况与我们在《心理学访谈》中讨论过的人为障碍（虚假疾病）之间的界限在哪里？在那种情况下，父母不仅经常带孩子看病，而且实际上还在做一些让孩子生病的事情。是的。是的，这与人为障碍非常不同。事实上，金，我很高兴你提到这一点，因为有时人们在看到焦虑的家长时，会想当然地认为这一定就是那种情况。我可以给出
you an example where I got a call from a pediatrician thinking this mother was doing that because every time her son got a fever, he was four. She would bring him into the ER and he'd have ice packs under each armpit and a neck ice pack. And she would be so terrified that he was going to have febrile seizures. He'd never had them. But this was a worry of hers that he would get febrile seizures and then become cognitively impaired. Why? Because she had had a cousin who had that happen at a young age, got, I think it was Rubella or German measles, something like that, got extremely ill and became, you know, extremely cognitively impaired. Well, there's a really easy way to tell, okay, if you're thinking about yourself or someone else. The first thing is, when we see
给你举个例子，我曾接到过一个儿科医生的电话，他认为这位母亲在这样做，因为每当她四岁的儿子发烧时，她就会把他带到急诊室，他的两个腋窝下和脖子上都放着冰袋。她非常害怕他会得高热惊厥。他以前从未有过。但这一直是她的担心，她担心他会得高热惊厥，然后导致认知受损。为什么？因为她有一个表亲在很小的时候就经历过这种情况，好像是得了风疹或德国麻疹之类的病，病情极其严重，结果你知道的，认知受到了极大的损害。嗯，有一个非常简单的方法可以分辨，好吧，如果你在考虑你自己或其他人。首先是，当我们看到
factitious disorder, the reactions of the parent are different than that of an anxious person. So we see they may show concern. They may have a lot of medical knowledge or information about the disorder, you know, or the things they're worried about. But we also have a child who is sick. Something's bad is happening to that child, where in this case, normally we would have a child or a spouse who's perfectly healthy. They just have something that's benign.
人为障碍（Munchausen综合征），父母的反应与焦虑的人不同。所以我们看到他们可能会表现出担忧。他们可能对这种疾病有很多医学知识或信息，你知道的，或者他们担心的事。但我们也有一个生病的孩子。那个孩子身上正在发生不好的事情，而在这种情况下，通常我们应该有一个完全健康的孩子或配偶。他们只是有些良性的问题。
That's one. And then also what we see is an anxious person cannot be reassured or consoled and that the reassurance is very short-lived where we see with factitious disorder as soon as there's this medical interaction, then that person is showing signs of, I'm going to say the parent I'm speaking about is basically showing satisfaction. You know, you're interacting with me and my child and they're seeming to be very cooperative. The other thing, you know, that we see is they don't express anxiety to the same degree and they aren't expressing this sort of terror of something terrible in the same way. And, you know,
这是其一。然后我们还看到，焦虑的人是无法被安慰或抚慰的，这种安慰是非常短暂的；而在人为障碍中，一旦有了这种医疗互动，这个人就会表现出迹象——我要说的是我正在谈论的这位母亲——基本上表现出了满足感。你知道的，你正在与我和我的孩子互动，他们看起来非常合作。另一件你知道我们看到的事是，他们不会表现出同等程度的焦虑，也没有以同样的方式表达对可怕事情的那种恐惧。而且，你知道，
I want you to think of it like this where if you've ever been anxious, you know, that feeling like you're being held under the pool too long, a car's about to hit you. Uh, you. Uh, or if you yourself have ever had a worry, what if this time it's cancer? Think of how you come across your actions, you're sweating, your heart rate, you're shaking, things like that. We don't see those same symptoms coming across the same way with factitious disorder. And that's one thing that tips off clinicians who are good observers is we don't see that consistent.
我希望你这样想：如果你曾经感到焦虑，你知道那种感觉，就像你被按在泳池底下太久，汽车快要撞到你了。呃，你。呃，或者如果你自己曾有过某种担心，如果这次是癌症呢？想想你是如何表现出你的行为的：你在出汗，心率加快，你在发抖，诸如此类。我们在人为障碍中看不到这些相同的症状以同样的方式表现出来。这是善于观察的临床医生能够察觉的一个迹象，那就是我们看不到这种一致性。
This is in response to anxiety in the parent. and to a symptom that is benign, as opposed to factitious disorder, we see the things they're doing to this person are dangerous and life-threatening, even, in many instances. Well, last question, any final words of wisdom to our audience, whether they themselves are anxious or they know somebody who has health anxiety? Well, the first thing I'd want to tell them is you don't have to continue with this, because many people I see come in telling me, I've never talked about this. My friends think I'm a worrywart.
这是对父母焦虑的反应，也是对良性症状的反应，与人为障碍相反，在许多情况下，我们看到他们对这个人做的事情是危险的甚至是危及生命的。最后一个问题，对于我们的听众，无论他们自己感到焦虑还是认识有健康焦虑的人，有什么最后的智慧之言吗？嗯，我想告诉他们的第一件事是，你不需要继续这样下去，因为我看到的许多人进来时都告诉我，我从未谈论过这个。我的朋友们认为我爱大惊小怪。
You probably can't do anything. And I think that's because it just hasn't been highlighted in the media as a disorder, as a solvable problem. So there is so much you can do treatments work well. The other thing I would want to tell you is a little bit of Buddhist, mindset is very helpful for that tragic kind of thinking. And one thing that we don't talk about a lot in Western culture is that we are going to die and we're frail and we're going to get sick and that dying and suffering are a normal part of our life and getting ill or having different
你可能什么也做不了。我认为这是因为它还没有作为一种疾病、作为一个可以解决的问题在媒体上得到强调。所以你可以做很多事情，治疗效果很好。我想告诉你的另一件事是，佛教的一些心态对那种悲剧性的思考非常有用。我们在西方文化中不太经常谈论的一件事是，我们终将一死，我们是脆弱的，我们会生病，死亡和痛苦是我们生活中的正常部分，生病或经历不同的
things happen that affect our health is normal. And we want to learn to accept that. And for most of us it takes a lifetime to truly accept it. So by the time that we face our death, we feel peaceful about it. But it's worth thinking about and realizing we all have to get sick. We all have to age and we all have to die. And we can think about it in a peaceful accepting. It must be possible because all of humanity has done this for all time versus that anxious way of imagining it to be something much worse than it is. And one of the best ways you can get in touch with this is if you've ever watched videos of people who are terminally ill or talked with them, I worked on an oncology unit a long time ago. I was expecting everybody to be all depressed and mournful. And they basically
影响我们健康的事情是正常的。我们要学会接受这一点。对我们大多数人来说，需要一生的时间才能真正接受这一点。因此，当我们面对死亡时，我们会对此感到平静。但这是值得思考的，并认识到我们都会生病。我们都会变老，我们都会死。我们可以用一种平静、接受的心态来思考它。这一定是有可能的，因为全人类在所有时间里都是这样做的，而不是用那种焦虑的方式把它想象得比实际情况糟糕得多。如果你看过绝症患者的视频或与他们交谈过，这是你能接触到这一点的最好方法之一。我很久以前在肿瘤科工作过。我以为每个人都会沮丧和哀伤。他们基本上
told me, honey, we aren't talking about death. We aren't talking about dying. We want to have fun. We're planning a picnic. And we planned fun things. This was a bunch of vets in Mississippi. And they had it right. They realized the very best antidote to death and dying is living a productive, meaningful life now, no matter what your circumstances are. And so I'd say, I want you to think about that and realize that's a skill we can all learn. It doesn't take anything special to be able to do that.
告诉我，亲爱的，我们不谈论死亡。我们不谈论垂死。我们想要快乐。我们在计划野餐。我们计划了有趣的事情。这是一群来自密西西比州的退伍军人。他们做对了。他们意识到对抗死亡和垂死的最好解药，就是现在过一种富有成效、有意义的生活，无论你的情况如何。所以我想说，我希望你思考这一点，并认识到这是一种我们都可以学习的技能。做到这一点不需要任何特殊的东西。
Well, that's great advice. I want to thank you, Dr. Cassidy, for joining me today. This has been very enlightening. Thank you so much, Kim. This has been a joy. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening.
这真是个好建议。卡西迪博士，非常感谢您今天能来。这非常具有启示意义。非常感谢你，金。这真是个快乐的过程。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上找到往期的《心理学谈话》节目，也可以在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology at APA.org。本期《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。谢谢收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. so it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state.
对于美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。在拉尔夫斯超市享受更多省钱方式，例如每个过道都有的低价。当您下载拉尔夫斯应用程序时，您可以每周通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。此外，您还可以赚取积分，在加油站每加仑节省高达 1 美元。在拉尔夫斯，您每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过储蓄和奖励，每天都可以轻松省大钱。拉尔夫斯南加州，已有 150 多年历史。各州省钱情况可能有所不同。
Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
燃油限制适用。详见网站。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。